[Music]
I'm going to talk about visualizing
uncertainty with hypothetical outcome
plots I just tweeted my slides so you
can find me on Twitter at Klaus Wilker
very easy to remember just my first name
my last name and I'm going to talk about
it's kind of an experimental package
which you can find here at this location
and again if you find the slides on
Twitter there will be the easiest to
find all of that ok so to motivate that
let's look at this extremely original
plot of cars you may have heard of it we
did not coordinate this so
fuel-efficiency miles per gallon in this
case plotted versus a displacement of
the engine and you see it's goes down
and I've fitted a nonlinear model here
and I'm sure you have seen plots like
that so you have this line that was
fitted and then this is gray band and
that tells us something about the
uncertainty of that fit right every time
we model something there's uncertainty
and we are used to displaying it like
this but what does that actually mean
right the truth is most people don't
know that I don't really know nobody
knows but it has to be there because if
it's not there you get complaints right
what's your uncertainty oh there's a
band okay now I know okay what that
really means is that I mean this line is
just one of multiple ways that we could
have fitted it and so there's really an
ensemble of different possible lines
right we could plot fitted drawers and
and that's not bad the fundamental
problem though is if we have the fitted
drawers okay there's the line that goes
here and then there's a little gap here
so does that mean the line would never
go here right can the line ever go here
so you don't know right and the problem
fundamentally with uncertainty is that
you don't know but when you see a plot
it looks certain right it's really
difficult to plot uncertainty because
the plot is kind of certain but it's not
certain and so there was this idea that
that
popularized very recently of the
hypothetical outcome plot was this paper
plus-one 2015 by Jessica Holman which is
to actually animate to cycle through
different potential fits and that to
some extent reduces this because it's
not static it's more clear that these
are alternatives and you don't really
exactly know what it would be but it's
something like that right so it's a much
more intuitive way of thinking or of
experiencing the uncertainty
okay so last August hadley tweeted
hypothetical outcome plots are a great
way of communicating uncertainty to non
experts and then he put forth this
challenge someone should make an assets
package to make these easier to create
would be easy on top of gg Anna made
famous three words okay so and I was
thinking I've done a lot of work with
ggplot lately and I really like GG
animate and I thought well maybe I can
do that let's see and so on what I'm
talking about today is really my my
discovery of what are the useful things
that maybe a package could contribute in
this world
okay so there's really three questions
that have this challenge poses so the
first one is how do we generate the
outcomes it's many different ways that
they could be generated so it's not
trivial once we have them how do we get
them into ggplot I'm just assuming we do
this with ggplot right GT animate though
you of course you could use some other
platform also if you wanted to and the
last one is is there anything to be done
I mean and you'll see in a second why
that is actually a meaningful question
so it's anything to be done immediately
after Hadley tweeted this there was this
following response you can make them
easily with tidy base in Gigi animate
the hop examples in this talk were done
that way I'm adding examples to the tidy
base vignettes when Gigi animate hits
cran okay done problem solved
well okay so this goes to how do we
generate outcomes right so we can do
Bayesian MCMC sampling that's what the
Tao dBase does and that's great but not
everybody is a Bayesian right or maybe
you can some models it just takes too
long to do MCMC sampling or whatever the
reason is you may want to do other
things so maybe you want a bootstrap
right resample the input data or maybe
you want to fit a regular regression
model and then just sample from the
normal approximation to the uncertainty
distributions that you can write so we
could argue that this is done with tidy
bases it's very natural in the Bayesian
framework to get these fitted draws that
then you just somehow get into GG
animate but the other two still need
some work okay so let's look into
bootstrapping so actually Alex Hayes
talked at the beginning of this session
if you were here what what's actually
the perfect introduction to my talk
because he explained why I was unhappy
with bootstrapping what he did to
bootstrap was terribly complicated right
was a lot of work which is which is fine
if you have a sophisticated
bootstrapping set up but I don't want to
do that I just want to do a few
bootstraps through plot right okay so
what I did is I bugged some people and
the person I mostly ended up back
bugging is David Vaughn who sits right
here running this and said we need an
easier way of doing this and so that's
coated now it's not yet really released
but it's going to be in our sample
eventually and it works as follows so if
we take say the iris data said we group
it and then we bootstrap if I it's the
magic word does the following if you
know the iris data said this is the iris
data said nothing has happened except
this now in groups if species of group
by species and it says bootstrap 15
because it's three species and we've
bootstrapped each five times so it says
virtual bootstraps that we've generated
that we can use in a deep liar sequence
so now we summarize we calculate the
mean sepal length
example and now the output we get five
numbers out here because we have five
bootstraps and we have the mean length
so that's about the level where I feel
comfortable with that's easy enough
I can live with that so now we can think
about how do we get this into ggplot
right so let's say this is our static
plot without any bootstrap and so now we
have to bootstrap right and make a
bootstrap data table I bootstrap 20
times here and this gives me the name of
the key column so which I group here and
so I get bootstrap plots okay that's
fine
it's still not easy enough and so this
is where I thought a little harder and I
think we can do it even easier and so
the problem here is which I
fundamentally dislike I'm piping the
data into the plot but I'm sticking
other data into the plot again right and
so if I want to do anything here in the
pipe before I put it into the data then
I also have to change this and it's just
too complicated right I want a bootstrap
in the plot now I could start writing
all sorts of special layers like geom
bootstrap smooth or whatever and I end
up writing a new layer for each type of
giome of stat you have and that's also
too complicated so I came up with the
following idea which uses a very
little-known feature from GD plot and so
this is this library under whist that I
wrote German word under base means
uncertain so it's like a play of words
if you're Germany understand it that's
the website I'm German as you probably
guessed by now okay so this is what it
does right the the key line is this line
so you can actually indeed you plot as
data give it a function that then does
something to the data and so
bootstrapper creates this function and
there the 20 is the argument of how much
do I want a bootstrap and so they
these six lines of code generate this
right and so now you see I feed in the
data once I plot points so the points
are just the original data set right and
the GM smooth I bootstrap and that's why
I how I get these bootstrap lines and
then of course I can connect that with
GG animate so if you don't know Gd
animate it's this really nice way of
animating plots so this is the only
additional thing that I need to do I say
I want to transition between draws and
then these two numbers are just how long
do I take to transition I transition
instantaneously how long do I stay in
the state and the one is then
meaningless it's just they all stay the
same amount of time and I get this nice
animated plot okay let's do another
example just to show you so we can do
different things we don't have to do
just smooth regression lines so
chocolate-bar ratings these visit data
set each dot is one chocolate bar rating
and the orange dots are the mean just to
show you on average so here we have USA
this kind of similar to other and then
Canada on average has a higher rating
than the US right but there's a lot of
us ratings not that many Canadian
ratings so we might want to know does a
randomly chosen Canadian chocolate bar
test taste better than a US one so
that's a common language effect size we
just take one US chocolate bar one
Canadian chocolate bar and we say which
one is better so the blue lines that are
jumping there those are the two bars
right you go in the store you bought by
two bars and then you go which of the
two is better and as you can see it's
it's sort of even the exact percentage
is actually 53 percent of the time
Canada is better and 47% of the time
u.s. as a draw is better with Canada and
you kind of get that right you see from
the jumping dots like it could really
come out either way okay so how do we do
that
so now we don't have to bootstrap right
we now have to sample and so the the
David Vaughn also wrote code for
sampling and I piggybacked on that and
wrote a feature to add that to Gigi plot
so we start with our data set here the
cocoa dataset we only take Canada and
the US so this is an example of how we
may want to process the data set before
we feed it into ggplot right rating and
location is what we want to plot first
we point a product plot a cloud of all
the ratings right that's as a GM point
and then I invented this GOM which i
think is needed and nobody had done it I
think if somebody has tell me and I'll
delete it from my package call this a
vertical point line it's like a point
but it's a line right and so this is now
here the key thing data now I instead of
bootstrapper I do sampler I sample 25
times but actually have to group because
I don't want a sample from the entire
data set right I want a sample
individually from Canada and the US what
I haven't specified is my sample size by
default it's one but I could sample
different sizes I could sample 10 or
whatever right the group is really
important if you don't specify the group
you might end up with two US chocolate
bars and no Canadian one and that
wouldn't work ok and then in the end oh
yeah this is just a little trick you
need to know if you don't do this then
the the lines they tween so they move
smoothly from one to the other which
looks nice but it's actually for
perception is not that great of a choice
so it's better to turn that off and then
again we animate and then that's the
result right okay so I think that's
that's a pretty efficient way to either
bootstrap a sample works with any genome
any stat right all you need is these two
functions bootstrapper and sampler and
the nice thing is
the bootstrapper if you assign it to a
variable then you can reuse it multiple
time in multiple layers so they'll all
bootstrap exactly the same way if you
look in the documentation you can see
how that works so you could like draw
lines and points or whatever on top of
each other and they'll all be bootstrap
exactly the same ok but there's still
this other thing right we can also
generate outcomes by normal
approximation to the sampling
distribution and I did some work on that
also and so I'll introduce that by
comparing to the bootstrapping so we'll
go back to the motocross example so that
was the example where we bootstrap and
now so now we have to write special
stats or Jeon so I I wrote this stat
smooth draws so instead of geum smooth
now I'm using stat smooth draw so that's
like it essentially a copy of stat
smooth so it draws a smooth line but it
does it multiple times it samples from
the posterior distribution now I don't
have to feed it in the data but I have
to tell how many draws I want right so
this is x equals 10 and I again have to
set the group but now because the draw
column is generated by the stat itself I
have to write stat of draw so here I
write this because really it's the draw
column as part of the data set that is
fed in like kind of it's done by this
function but 2gd part it looks like it's
the data that it comes in versus this is
something that happens in the
statistical transformation and then
these are the two plots and they look
kind of similar you if you do it enough
you can see that the bootstraps they
tend to be more grouped you get like
kind of sets of bootstraps that kind of
look the same in this particular plot
it's not that obvious but conceptually
it makes sense because bootstrap you add
or remove entire points right either the
point is there it's not there with the
fitted draws you smoothly sample the
entire space of possibilities and then
this
actually also works with GD animate so
gg animate understands that it can
transition on columns that have been
generated by the staff and so then you
get this okay so just very quickly
because the people that invented pop
hops care a lot about so there's
different ways that you could animate
this right I've been using hard
transitions you could do hard
transitions but on a background of all
the outcomes I don't know if it's it's
sort of visible right okay
you could fade outcomes this is not
really like you can sort of see it they
fade out and the new one comes in or you
can't win between outcomes this is
actually the default that GD animate
will do if you don't tell it otherwise
it looks very fancy but the perception
researchers argue that this doesn't
really work as well to person so in
psychology and experiments people have a
harder time judging the uncertainty from
these kinds of graphs than from these
kinds of graphs so it seems that the
general consensus is this or this is the
best way to do it and that's really it
my take-home messages as make Hobbs it's
easy this is the website but since we
have a little bit toilet there's a bonus
so this just to show off right so
there's a bootstrapping example where
you actually see the individual dots how
often they've been resampled right so
for example if you look here it's now at
0 now it's 1 now it's 0 now it's 3 1
right and you see also when this one
gets 0 the line ends and now it's there
again right and then when this turns to
0 the line now it starts here right so
it's really visualizes how the bootstrap
operates and that's the code that does
it and so this is that's all you need
for that right this is the trick here
I'm assigning this bootstrapper to an
object and then I'm using it here to
draw points here to draw a tack
and here to draw the bootstrap lines and
so they all see exactly the same
bootstrap right and so that makes it
easy to make really quite fancy
visualizations hopefully easily that's
all I have thank you
thanks class it was really cool any
questions
we definitely have some time really cool
can you hear me does this okay yeah I'm
curious a little bit about how much we
know about how these how much these work
better and about how well people are
interpreting in certainty out of these
sorts of things so yeah there's two
research papers as fine aware so it's
it's a really active research in the two
papers that have been published in
indirect comparisons where people had to
judge like how uncertain something is
from a harp versus some other
visualization of uncertainty generally
people get a better sense of the
uncertainty from the hop and people are
better at actually judging accurately
what the chance for example is I mean
like you have to judge are you getting
the train or not like what's the chance
if you get a coffee now versus not that
you're going to catch the train and
people do better with these hop type of
uncertainties than just like arrow bars
or something like that another question
can you have confidence bands with
animations can you can you repeat have
confidence bands with the animations
that standard error around so for
instance that the top-right graph you
had all the possible lines can you also
add the confidence bands to that yeah I
mean it's it's just a plot right so you
just layer them on top of each other so
you could use so with the conference
band there's this little subtle problem
in the sense that if you use the GM
smooth to draw the confidence bandit use
slightly different math from my own stat
smooth have to do a little more work but
it's like three additional lines and
it's shown in the in the vignettes that
I wrote for the package I mean yeah just
lay a plot lay us on top of each other
and you show whatever you want to show
yeah maybe one more
thanks really cool talk I'm just
wondering has anybody asked you about
maybe incorporating p-values into this
you know bootstrapping visualization and
if somebody we're gonna ask you about it
how would you respond so in my in my day
job I'm scientists I'm a biologist I've
seen lots of figures in my life I've
never seen a p-value of visualization
that I thought was useful or credible so
I really don't know I mean that doesn't
mean it's not possible it's just I've
never seen it I don't know how to
visualize p-values in a way that is
useful
[Music]